Tradutor: Felipe Lacerd
Revisor: Leonardo Silva
A tecnologia transformou a minha vida.
Essa sou eu, um ano de idade,
meu primeiro computador.
Pequenina, já adorava mexer em tudo.
Meus pais me educaram
até os oito anos de idade.
Minha mãe me ensinou a escola da vida.
Mas ela sempre perdia
muito tempo no banco,
e eu adorava brincar de banco
e sempre esperava ansiosa por ela
com os papéis de depósito.
Eu falava: "Mãe, você não precisa
perder tanto tempo no banco.
Quando eu crescer, eu vou montar
o banco dos bancos,
e aí, você pode fazer tudo em um só".
Mas é um banco que eu cobrava
o juros do banco.
Um banco diferente:
que dava, que não tirava.
Cresci com isso em mente,
mas, aos 12 anos de idade,
foi onde tudo começou.
Meus pais sofreram um acidente de carro,
e foi aí que tive que me virar.
Foi aí que, pela primeira vez,
a tecnologia salvou a minha vida.
Foi onde eu comecei a fazer website.
Meu primeiro website eu não vendi,
eu fiz de graça. Fiz pra um restaurante.
Aí eu fui no vizinho,
no concorrente, e falei:
"Olha, seu vizinho tem um website".
Isso, 18 anos atrás, nossa senhora...
era superluxo.
Aí ele falou: "Tá bom, tá bom..."
Eu insistia tanto que ele...
Eu pegava um cartão de visita e falava:
"Está muito feio, eu consigo fazer melhor.
Se eu fizer bonito você me paga?"
E assim eu comecei,
sendo empreendedora para sobreviver.
Foi muito difícil.
Tive que amadurecer,
quando criança, muito rápido.
E ser empreendedora no Brasil não é fácil.
Como mulher...
ainda mais difícil.
Enfrentei muito obstáculos;
um deles, o acesso ao crédito.
O segundo, a parte de mentoria,
suporte e apoio de que eu precisava.
O terceiro era o respeito,
no trabalho e nas relações, como mulher.
Tive que trabalhar às vezes
cinco vezes mais do que o colega homem,
para me destacar.
E também o acesso à inovação.
Mas eu fiz de sistemas pro governo
pra monitorar hidroelétricas
a jogos e aplicativos.
Cresci muito,
amadureci,
quebrei empresa,
construí de novo, caí, levantei...
caí de novo, levantei...
E quem sempre estava ali do meu lado
pra me inspirar era meu pai.
Meu pai conseguiu inovar
num lugar chamado governo.
Ali, em 1996, ele criou
um programa chamado PRONAF:
Programa Nacional da Agricultura Familiar.
Esse programa dava acesso e oportunidade
às pessoas na área rural
e ajudou também todo
o sistema cooperativo a crescer.
Isso me inspirou muito,
mas o governo era difícil,
a gente via a burocracia.
A gente via o tanto que demorava
pra um agricultor ter acesso
a um caixa eletrônico:
100 km, em média.
Empréstimos como o do governo demoravam
cerca de 120 dias pra serem liberados.
Muita coisa.
E a média quando ia
pra um banco privado, e até hoje,
é mais ou menos de 143%
de taxa de juros anuais.
É muito caro.
E isso quando você não precisa
de algo emergencial,
porque, vai ver, você quebra uma máquina
ali de que precisa pra irrigar o café,
e se você não irrigar o café naquela data,
você perde a safra do ano inteiro.
Aí, você vai pra onde? Cartão de crédito.
Aí sim, os juros são de 1000 a 3000%
e, quando você não paga o mínimo,
aí vira uma bola de neve.
Então, na realidade,
quem está nessa situação
de ou não ter uma conta bancária
ou estar com o nome negativado
são 80 milhões de brasileiros,
13 milhões passando fome.
Então, eu descobri na tecnologia
um meio de ajudar,
um meio de conectar as pessoas.
E foi daí que surgiu a Moeda.
O que é a Moeda?
A moeda mais comum que a gente
conhece hoje é esta nota.
Mas se a gente for tirar esta nota aqui,
ela não tem dono, ela não tem o meu nome,
não está escrito "Taynaah" aqui.
Se eu der esta nota pra um mendigo na rua,
eu não sei se ele vai comprar cachaça
ou se vai ajudar a família.
Mas imagina se a esta nota
eu consigo anexar a minha identidade?
Se eu consigo anexar
a minha identidade a esta nota,
ela já tem um valor,
ela já consegue ser transferida.
Mas imagina que eu possa anexar também
a essa nota, essa identidade, um contrato,
que eu saiba exatamente
onde eu vou gastar esse dinheiro.
Então, posso mandar
esses R$ 100 pra África
e eu sei que médico eu estou ajudando,
que criança eu estou ajudando,
que medicamento eu estou comprando.
Então, é pensando nisso,
em agregar o valor do dinheiro,
agregar a identidade,
agregar um contrato,
que você vê o poder do blockchain.
O blockchain é um protocolo.
Hoje é uma das tecnologias
de ponta no mundo.
Vocês vão ouvir falar
bastante do blockchain.
Com o blockchain, eu posso ir além.
O maior caso de sucesso
do blockchain foi o bitcoin.
Com o bitcoin, você consegue fazer
uma transação financeira
do outro lado do mundo, em segundos,
passar um dinheiro,
e você tem a sua identidade, seu endereço,
sua assinatura atrelada a ele.
Então, ali você não precisa
de um intermediário.
O intermediário é o banco.
Porque o banco cobra muito caro
para falar que eu sou a Taynaah,
que eu sou dona do meu dinheiro,
que você é dono do seu dinheiro.
As taxas são absurdas.
E o tempo, nem se fala.
Então, imagina que, ao contrato,
a gente possa anexar também
objetivos e metas pra serem cumpridas.
Esses são os Objetivos do Desenvolvimento
Sustentável das Nações Unidas,
onde todos nós aqui temos responsabilidade
de ajudar a combater a fome, a pobreza,
a criar mais igualdade de gênero.
Imagine se tudo isso a gente consegue
colocar numa caixa, num bloco,
e consegue que esse bloco
tenha esse cadeado,
seja um bloco transparente,
e essa informação não pode ser deletada.
Esse é o poder do blockchain:
você não pode deletar as informações,
todas as elas são compartilhadas
de forma transparente
e, com isso, a gente vence
uma batalha muito grande,
que é a batalha com que
esse país sofre demais,
que é a batalha da corrupção.
Eu construí a minha carreira lá fora.
Morei em Nova Iorque,
em Londres, na Suécia.
Não foi fácil.
Não foi fácil ouvir do meus colegas:
"Ah não, não vou investir no país não.
O seu país está muito bagunçado.
"A política lá... o que está acontecendo?
O presidente... o que é isso?"
Eu falava: "Poxa...
não quero isso.
Como a gente faz para mudar?
Como a gente faz para conectar
as pessoas do bem,
para dar voz às pessoas do bem?"
E é aí que eu vi o poder da transparência,
que a gente precisa de uma revolução,
não é tecnológica,
mas uma revolução da confiança,
pras pessoas poderem acreditar
que, sim, existem pessoas boas no nosso
país que estão fazendo a diferença
e que elas merecem ter crédito,
ter acesso à mentoria, ter respeito
e ter acesso à inovação.
Agora você imagina que pessoas
do outro lado do mundo
possam se conectar
a pessoas aqui no Brasil.
Na Moeda, nós tivemos
cerca de 841 investidores,
em sua maioria chineses.
E o engraçado é que
a maioria é de chineses
e entre 20 e 28 anos de idade, jovens,
investindo em projetos daqui, do Brasil,
de mulheres agroempreendedoras,
nas áreas rurais,
que, agora sim, têm voz.
Então, a capacidade de conectar,
a capacidade de criar essa confiança,
esse laço, de fortificar,
ajudou a dar voz às nossas empreendedoras.
Tem um estudo grande do Banco Mundial,
que fala sobre o Grameen Bank,
sobre a questão do Muhammad Yunus,
o banco do povo,
que prova que as mulheres
são boas pagadoras.
As mulheres pensam em longo prazo,
pensam em gerações.
Então, elas conseguem
multiplicar o dinheiro,
multiplicar o impacto desse dinheiro.
A maioria da renda vai pra família:
80% da renda é reinvestida na família
quando o dinheiro está
na mão de uma mulher.
E a gente sabe que nosso país,
nosso Brasil, é um país machista.
A mulher trabalha, mas é o homem
que fica ali no caixa, com a carteira.
A gente tem que mudar essa realidade,
empoderar a mulher,
a mulher que está do nosso lado.
E você imagina: se pra mim foi difícil,
que cresci na cidade, fui morar fora,
imagina pra uma
empreendedora na área rural,
ter acesso a crédito, a essa rede.
Então, foi pensando nisso
que eu enxerguei que a tecnologia
podia dar voz a essas mulheres,
pra elas contarem a história delas.
Quem melhor que elas
pra contar a própria história
e pra ter acesso direto ao investidor,
sem nenhum intermediário,
pra contar quanto que elas vão impactar
com aquele dinheiro?
E pra a gente auditar o processo inteiro,
de forma transparente,
utilizando tecnologia...
Então o investidor vai ver desde o início,
desde a criação do plano de negócios,
até a disponibilização do crédito;
o crédito vai voltar,
o impacto vai acontecer,
mudanças vão ser geradas,
e está ali registrado,
num banco também de conhecimento,
pra não reinventar mais a roda.
Eu queria contar a história
da Dona Divina.
Dona Divina é de Formosa, Goiás.
Ela me mata de orgulho.
Meu pai, dez anos atrás, conseguiu
fundar a primeira cooperativa dela.
É uma cooperativa de produção
onde ela juntava ali os cooperados
pra processar polpa de fruta,
pra colher baru.
E ela, ali,
no meio de Formosa, a 100 km dum banco,
conseguiu impactar 170 famílias
nesses dez anos, que ela ajuda.
A gente foi lá e foi além.
Porque não é só ensinar a pescar, hoje.
É ensinar a pescar, dar o peixe,
ajudar a vender o peixe...
Isso é que faz a diferença.
Então, a gente foi lá no governo,
conversamos com o prefeito:
"Não, vamos...
vender diretamente seu produto
aqui pras escolas".
Então, com isso a gente conseguiu
contratos pra ela,
e ela vai ter uma garantia de receita;
então, gerar emprego e renda.
Foi isso que meu pai em ensinou, sempre.
Tem que ajudar a pessoa a crescer,
de forma independente,
com as próprias pernas.
Então, com os investimentos,
a produção dela cresceu cinco vezes.
E ela está feliz porque agora,
com a tecnologia,
e com ela tendo essa possibilidade
de contar a história,
são menos intermediários.
Ela vendia um pacote de baru a R$ 5.
Vendia pra outra pessoa, que vendia
pra um atravessador, que vendia pra outro,
e chegava lá no mercado o saquinho
desse tamanho, R$7, R$ 8.
Então, o que ela perdia no processo...
Então, a gente conectou a Dona Divina
com muito mais gente.
E é o poder não só do crédito;
agora, é o poder da rede.
Porque quando a gente conecta
as pessoas certas,
a gente consegue multiplicar.
Então, com os intermediários,
ela perdia muito.
Indo diretamente, hoje ela pode vender
uma gotinha dum óleo de baru,
e botar num produto de cabelo,
e esse produto ser vendido por R$ 50.
Então, o poder da tecnologia,
o poder do blockchain,
o poder da nossa moeda,
nossa moeda é a moeda da transparência.
Porque é muito fácil
às vezes a gente julgar,
mas, quando a gente julga,
é um paradoxo, né?
A gente julga uma pessoa,
aponta um dedo, fala:
"Ah, o problema é do governo,
o problema é da corrupção".
Mas a gente esquece que tem três dedos
aqui apontados para nós.
O que a gente está fazendo?
Vou contar também a história da Sandra.
Ela é catarinense, aqui de Chapecó.
Nossa, a Sandra é uma
supermulher, superguerreira.
Ela juntou muito dinheiro.
Foi juntando um pouquinho...
Via lá um edital do governo pra comprar
uma máquina de pasteurização de leite,
ia lá, corria num banco
que tinha um outro edital,
participava pra comprar outra máquina,
e ela conseguiu montar toda a estrutura
de uma fábrica de leite,
mas o principal ela não conseguiu,
que foi o capital de giro.
O país também tem um problema:
tem dinheiro para muitas
coisas desconectadas,
mas, pro principal, pra você rodar sua
empresa ali durante 60 dias, não tem,
o dinheiro sai caro.
Então, disponibilizando
o dinheiro pra Sandra,
agora aquela fábrica imensa
que ela conseguiu botar de pé,
que estava parada,
vai rodar.
Então, a gente vê que é simples:
que está dentro de cada um,
que a tecnologia que a gente tem hoje
possibilita a cada um de nós transformar.
E o que a gente precisa
é da revolução da cooperação.
Vamos cooperar
pra que cada mulher
do nosso lado seja empoderada,
pra que cada um seja tocado
e que a gente transforme,
juntos, muitas vidas.
Meu pai... ninguém sabe
porque ele nunca divulgava,
mas ele ajudou diretamente
3 milhões de pessoas,
com os programas ali
e tentando inovar dentro do governo.
Mas era tudo limitado.
Minha meta é um pouco mais ambiciosa.
Com a tecnologia e com o apoio de cada um,
daqui e de lá do outro lado
do mundo, da China,
e dos outros países que estão dispostos
a ajudar as mulheres
guerreiras aqui do país,
minha meta são 3 bilhões.
E acho que a gente vai conseguir, juntos.
Vai demorar um tempo
pra cada um acordar o coração,
pra cada um, em vez de deixar o dinheiro
ali no banco, parado na poupança -
que vai render o quê, 5%? -
poder investir na Dona Divina,
na Dona Sandra, na Dona Maria,
e ter 5%, 8%;
mudar o conceito do que é investir,
pra investir em pessoas.
Obrigada.
(Aplausos)